foreign
this mission of yours
cost
ing dearly
ever since I saw the featurette of you
on the motorcycle I've been wanting to
ask you this question yes there's a
moment before you go on the first run
and you look off to the end of the ramp
and you go
do you remember this moment what was
that okay there's two things okay one it
was okay
I'm gonna do this that did feel that
emotion he's like okay let's go because
I didn't know what was going to happen
it was the first day of filming look
I've spent years preparing for this it's
not just not just the years prepping and
figuring it out but I've been riding
motorcycles since I was a little kid but
parachuting training constantly
developing kind of for years developing
developing knowledge developing
technology on how to shoot these things
and really how to tell a story it's not
just capturing an image but it's how do
we tell a story so when I was on the
ramp I was thinking
we're gonna see how this goes you don't
be cute I talked about it I know the
camera as that as that helicopter is
going across heat we had to be in sync
because he could have blown me off that
ramp so his his timing my speed had to
be perfect
to adjust the camera so I was I
everything The rhythms of everything we
had to do and everything we trained
now's the moment where I'm going off the
cliff and
and I'm thinking of performance
and it was also it was a nod it also was
a cue to tell everyone I'm about to go
okay so it was keying off everyone I
called my own action so they said action
but no one went I had to find something
where I didn't take my hands off the
bike like I couldn't give a hand signal
and I also wanted to be part of
performance where you just seen my head
went down I went like that that told the
helicopter I'm going it told the drones
I'm going and so all of that timing came
off and once I did that I had to release
a bike yeah so I go like that and that's
the moment I must release the bike
otherwise all of the everything's the
sink is going to be off and would also
affect
just the you know the Dynamics of doing
something like that the downdraft from
the helicopter where the position of the
Drone is going to be all the camera
operators so that when I'm going off and
you know yeah you finally flew without a
plane I know it was amazing speaking of
McHugh
he told a little story
that after the first you could tell a
good story he tells a great story after
the first screening of every Mission
Impossible film he whispered his ear and
you say we could
that's just every Mission Impossible
it's just Mission Impossible every movie
we make I look at it and I'm watching it
so we can do better even Top Gun even
Maverick always you think you can make a
better Maverick oh I think I can't are
you going to
that's the question so how do you when
you say after Fallout how did you
improve on it because I do really
believe I just watched the entire Series
in succession I do really believe that
you have improved on every single one
but how do you do that as a filmmaker
and as an actor and then how are you
going to do that for the second part of
this one you know we're always looking
at how we always story is it immersive
I'm every since I was a kid I've studied
movies I've studied Studios distribution
traveled the world and watched films
with audiences all over the world their
movies and their culture and my films to
see how they translate and I'm always
going how can I hone a story to to make
it as immersive as possible and with
each one I'm constantly learning the
amazing thing about this art form the
amazing thing about this life is that
you're constantly learning it's both
fantastic and terrible you know I mean
you're like oh my gosh you know and
we're constantly pushing it to that next
level not just with stunts but Story how
can we with the resources that we have
give up give a a better experience or
immersive experience for an audience so
those things it and it's just like I'm
going I'm not going to try to compete
but all the things that I've learned in
terms of character development
um story structure how to you know
filming you know we're all I'm always
challenging myself on a daily basis and
my crew and McHugh and I back and forth
going really thinking in terms of just
what's connecting me to the story or not
what's connecting me to the environment
or not so here we are shooting in Rome
and also looking at the city and not
trying to put something in that
is a forcing the geography we're going
what's this what's the geography telling
us what is what story can we tell you
have an actress like Haley well when we
you know someone who we've admired for
many years and thought when when we were
thinking this movie when you when we
meet her we're going what story can we
tell with Ethan
and we knew you know we wanted to go
in back more into the history and pull
up Henry Cerny and and really you just
felt the movie wanted to do it and I had
felt that the franchise had earned it so
those are the things that I'm I'm
constantly
constantly looking like for me it's
you know and I'm
I don't know how many films I've
produced I don't know how many films
I've overseen uh but that is how I feel
about it I want I want to not just say
I'm gonna try to outdo myself but going
what is this story and how can I take
this kind of story and from my knowledge
of audiences Global audiences how can I
tell the story in the same manner but
engage a broader audience as best I can
you've been running a movie since 1981.
two of my favorite runs are in this one
and you do a lot of running in this one
it was actually queue just has me
running every time he's like I can you
and they're getting longer they are but
they're getting more option we all see
you run we all enjoy you Ronnie your
fans love you running but how do you
actually train for it because you're
training for do you do have personal
best that you up you're grinning now
because it's like it's a very good
question because yeah it's interesting
because I have to go through it and I'm
look at just as an actor and in my life
I've always
train just to make movies because the
endurance and the you know I train in
many things singing dancing you know
Motorcycles Cars and also in my personal
life I like doing I like skydiving speed
flying and all these things and I like
to then go learn these things and then
apply it to the movies but it's a it is
a real trick and I I have gone through
to figure out how do I train how do I
maintain how do you hit Peak right at
the moment because also when I'm when
I'm doing a sprinting scene I don't just
run once I have to run oh like sometimes
I've done 50 Sprints in one day which is
so I have to think about what the
recovery time is
what scenes I'm shooting before and
after and I've gotten better at really
structuring things within the film and
sitting down and going I here's because
I have to prepare for the jump off the
motorcycle so there's certain things and
you're using different your body in a
different way or if I'm doing gymnastics
or a fighting scene you know you don't
want to do a fight right there when I'm
going to Sprint and how do I prepare and
how do I recover uh and also the hours
that I work I work seven days a week and
I'm producing so it's it's just a you
know and everything else that we are
dealing with during this time period it
was you know but I I enjoy the I have to
say
I enjoy the pressure I do enjoy the
challenge of it I realized like I woke
up I you know what I enjoy this I like
putting myself through in in these kinds
of situations the last question I heard
you just say you never think it's big
enough yes
the next couple of stunts McHugh gave me
a little tease he says the last shot in
this one sets up one of the stunts in
the next one which we can assume what
that is but we've also seen shots of you
out on the plane
walking out on the plane did you go
bigger in this one than in I can't tell
you
I can tell you we went bigger I
shouldn't tell you that I could tell you
but then I'd have to kill you
if we just hurt me a little bit that's a
lie for Top Gun but in this one then
yeah which one of the three sequences do
you think was
the biggest in terms of as a producer
and actor uh you know what each one has
been very challenging each one was
really fun because look we built the
Train the train is real we had to build
the train to put it down a track to send
it off the track
all this stuff and and also what I enjoy
is you know this the action that I do
with palm with Haley the driving through
here the streets on the Cobblestone
one-handed because like you're gonna
have you could be handcuffed oh my gosh
okay so I'm practicing drifting and the
Fiat had a very you know small wheelbase
so it would catch on the cobblestones
and Haley and I are in the car togethers
are doing it each one had a different
kind of Adventure about it and and a
different challenge always with
motorcycles it's it's challenging
because you're looking at it but I don't
have pads so I can I rehearse all the
jumps and everything with the pads and
high speed and I'm always going very
very high speed so uh that stuff's
always even though there's little small
jumps you know the things that I'm doing
ahead of time they're always a little
tricky a little you know rocks and
different things like that so it's never
boring every morning there was there was
a bit of Adventure and also the the base
jumping that we did you can see in the
EPK
you can see me jumping out of the
helicopter I was testing the wind inside
the bowl and it wasn't just once I get
off the ramp but still I have to once I
open
the challenge is I have to open in a
manner that
if I'm destabilized in any way the Chute
will open in in different ways and they
packed it beautifully for me and it was
very important that I always had the
same team with me but and you could see
I opened in the parachute open a way
that threw me into the side of the
mountain and I'm and you can see I'm
just you have to really be ready that
when it opens that if I'm with this and
I was about this close to the to the
side of the mount that you pull the you
know you get the parachute very quickly
very quickly away from not dragging the
any piece of the parachute on the Rock
so every day there was some there was
there was a challenge which I like plus
Performance Plus you know it's not just
about me it's about our whole cast and
really that's why
we're happy to put the uh the bike jump
out because they thought they saw it and
they've never seen it you won't see it
until you see the movie there's another
shot that's that has I'm we're so low as
I'm getting to the ground it's right
over me as I'm going very low to the
ground you can see that shot there to
get that shot was was very interesting
and we know that
we're happy to send that out because we
know we have the whole train we know you
have the whole you know horses in the
beginning you know all the horseback
riding all of that stuff in the desert
in a sandstorm my favorite moments with
you as much as we love the big moments
the Ethan Quiet Moments you need that
balance in the film and I love that
McHugh will Linger on a shot just long
enough you'll tell the team I got it and
there'll be that little bit of Doubt so
how much joy do you still get into those
Quiet Moments as much as you love the
big moments you know if I love all of
the moments I I have to say all of those
moments and also when I see the other
actors and we're constantly working with
them to what's in what I love in movies
I want Vivid characters it's not it's
not
it's not about me it's about the story
and it's about how do we tell this story
to engage an audience into an emotional
story and a character journey and
there's this other stuff that we have
there's another there's it's the amount
of time that we spend
finding the story finding those moments
with the characters and not just for
myself but the other actors in
developing that stuff that's what
engages me and then I Want To Thrill the
audience also with these other things
because you if you don't have that it
doesn't matter how big it is if I'm not
invested in the story and invested with
the characters and that that is primary
for us and that's what keeps the
franchise going it's not just this yeah
it's just movies why I want to see
movies I want to care about the people I
want to be interested in the world I
want to be interested in those people
that is movies I'm using all of the
skills that I and the things that I love
in cinema
and all of the dramatic and comedic and
all those films and the character
development that we have and we're
looking and I'm developing that with all
the actors and then putting it all we're
doing is putting a big landscape on top
of that right right that's all it's you
know from any other kind of movie that
I've done how do you have that emotion
while you're juggling how do you have
that the thing with this movie that I
when you're looking at the Fiat and
you're looking at Haley and I we're
playing those scenes in a two shot now
we don't have a bunch of takes that we
can do those characters have to be
connected and you have to find those
moments like that and that kind of skill
to be able to play that kind of moment
and comedy that normally I get to have
in a Jerry Maguire yeah or a Rain Man
you know or a cocktail where you have
that you're on the ground you're doing
that we're doing it at high speed
and having it feel organic because it is
organic it's happening now but you have
to have actors that first we have to get
him used to that kind of speed and that
kind of pace and that kind of action now
you know the scene on the train it's
like you trust me no those those kind of
character moments that are real that
invest me
in these people and that's the thing
always with with Ethan I was like look
the key with this character and people
like oh you know no he does this it's
like he doesn't want to have to do that
he has to do it and you know when he's
about to go off that cliff
he when what he's thinking about what's
interesting and what's what what I want
in it is that emotional investment as to
why he's doing it we understand it's not
just ta-da we're not going Tada it's the
it's story that's getting us there and
anyone that understands that level of
performance that level of Storytelling
understands like I could have that
that's the same kind of emotional
investment that you have in a movie that
we're shooting in a room that's that's
what I'm always looking for I'm looking
for audience engagement
character audience engagement with that
and and telling our story we're not
altering our story or what I want to do
but there's many different ways where I
can I can push an audience away or I can
pull them into my story and I can pull
them into a character and
those are the things that you know I've
played supporting roles and I've played
the lead roles so I I know structurally
every aspect of how to draw
how to draw an audience in and when do I
want to draw them in and when do I want
to push them away you know with those
different kinds of characters and that's
that's constantly the evaluation
um as we're going through it so it's not
just as an actor I'm not going
it is character development and it's
it's but it's the whole it's the whole
story it's every actor in there you know
when we're casting the actors it's we're
looking at them going okay what how do I
celebrate their talent which is you know
in old Hollywood they would look people
and it's like and they built
performances for them that's what I do
if you look at my movies all the way
back when I was a young actor you look
at Risky Business you look at A Few Good
Men you look at Rain Man you look at
these movies my my taste in my
development is looking at actors and
celebrating them and that it's it's us
together and how where do I put that
camera how do we write these lines how
do we develop it in a manner that is
immersive for an audience you know
because then you're seeing all these
great characters and that's those kind
of movies I love and those those are the
kind of movies that I tried to and
aspire to make so you're like the old
lady that gave you the quarter you're
giving the quarterback that's it yeah
that's great yes yes yes that's it
that's exactly it